[Music]
all right ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee congressman Devin
Nunez is now preparing to send eight
criminal referrals to the Attorney
General William bar over the alleged
misconduct or any Trump Russia
investigation also just breaking now
Devin Nunez has filed a one hundred and
fifty million dollar lawsuit against
McClatchy news and alleging conspiracy
to derail the Clinton Russia probes
congressman joins us now at the very
latest let's start with your lawsuit
well this is the same McClatchy that
said that Michael Kohn was in Prague
when Michael I knew where Michael Kohn
was his son is a great athlete his son
he was in Los Angeles with his son well
let's just say showing off his sons
great talent agzam Prague and he's
doubled down on stupid but that's only
when is that twice Sean so they had
dozens and dozens of story so a couple
of reporters there were the biggest
perpetuators of the Russia hoax and
don't forget they also targeted the
National Rifle Association they targeted
a lawyer
clida Mitchell so all of this was done
in concert while they were slandering
and attacking me and defaming me
attacking Republicans in the whole time
they were getting this information from
someone and so part of the lawsuit here
is not only that you know they need to
retract everything that they did against
me but they also need to come clean with
the American people retract all of their
fake news stories and so this is part of
the broader cleanup so remember a few
weeks ago I filed against Twitter that
they're censoring conservatives
McClatchy is one of the biggest the
worst offenders of this but we're coming
after the rest of them I think people
are just beginning to wake up now that
I'm serious I'm coming to clean up all
the mess so if you're out there and you
lied and you defamed we're gonna come
after you well I would add to the list
you know the Cowardly shift you know
I've offered him an hour on this show
and I have a dossier on [ __ ] yeah I
can't sue I can't sue him but I can't
take the documented I offered him three
hours on radio in one hour
here he doesn't take it up but but he
doesn't want to tell you I guess he's
afraid I got a tape of him colluding
with a Russian was somebody believed to
be a Russian that had compromising
materials and naked pictures of Trump
and you know he was hyperventilating on
the phone called didn't know he's being
it was a hoax
and don't forget even after that the
staff the Democratic staff followed up
so the media ignored that's another
thing that they ignored so there's two
things that happened this right you had
fake news stories that were very
slanderous that have got to be wiped
away and cleaned off the internet and at
the same time you had that they would
take these stories in ignore them like
the fact that you had staffers here that
were attempting to collude with Russians
democratic staffers colluding with
Russians trying to get information on
Donald Trump I mean that really happened
and it's went you know largely
unreported it except by there are a few
in the conservative media and we also
had the Hillary bought and paid for
dossier real Russian paid for to
influence the election now we've got the
we've got evidence Ukraine the Ukrainian
officials on them with evidence that a
taped joe biden bragging they fired him
I don't have a lot of time I want to get
to the criminal referral issue I know
you begin with eight but there might be
more what can you tell us and how soon
yeah so the simply put there's five that
are straightforward so five online
leaking obstructing Congress those are
five five specific names there are three
one is a global leak referral so
remember there's been I mean everybody
knows about general the leak between
general Flynn and the Russian ambassador
we don't know that that's ever been
investigated but there's about a dozen
others so we're referring all those to
make sure they get the proper sunlight
put on them and transparency so that
they can be followed up on the other two
I think are more difficult that that are
involved conspiracy I think there are a
bunch of people who wanted to be the
next Watergate [ __ ] within the FBI
and DOJ and they were leaking and they
were proud to do it and they were all
conspiring together and that's what
we're asking the DOJ to look into if we
don't hold them accountable for this
abuse of power this corruption at the
highest levels to first influence and
help one candidate over another and then
and then literally upend the
intellection and the American people it
will happen again and again we'll lose
the Republic holding them accountable
zki Thank You congressman